[Music]
work it work it work it quick how's the
OMS - we're gonna do the kidney
transplant yes
I'll read your Bros comments and I think
we're ready for this [ __ ] aren't we Bob
you're in my domain now [ __ ]
so a lot of you both said that you don't
want me as your surgeon don't make me
slap you again don't make me slap you
don't really get what you mean by that
why isn't he not working Bob why is it
not that the working I'm such a
professional Hey eat it eat it
see if I care dick now I don't bite me
light saber oh [ __ ] sorry about that
Bobby burn his nipples little bit nice
and easy there we go oh shut sorry about
that Bobby bow but little laser go oh
not on me but calm down
off with the lights are off with the
Liza drill did I tell you to start
dancing no I did [ __ ] not let's grab
this whole thing oh I love your new
scarf Bob Oh or your fabulous love it I
was going so well that's right
[Music]
that's my slapping sound effect don't
even worry about holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
I don't want to be a doctor anymore nope
don't you - fine Meg Oh
[Music]
that's right I'm the boss of you [ __ ]
okay okay okay next you know they [ __ ]
okay don't you die blade on me Bob I
will [ __ ] kill you if you die oh it's
in [ __ ] perfect match I will make us
a perfect mate we're like Oh bye that
was [ __ ] awesome
sergeant complete looks fine to me I'm
sure lift all right next up Russ brain
transplant that'll be great
Miranda use dirty [ __ ] stop calling me
[Music]
[Applause]